welcome everybody to off the rails
without ela with ethan klein uh
experience thank you thank you thank you
it's not a podcast it's an experience
you know how we do it
today pardon me
i'm tired man i'm i feel a little off
this show because
i don't know i did this trainer again
yesterday the one that keeps yelling
money at me
and my back i've had like chronic back
pain and i couldn't sleep
that didn't seem right right not like
good like muscle
pain like back injury pain you know what
i mean
that that's just not money but it's not
money
so i don't know i didn't sleep basically
um but that's not going to stop us from
coming here and doing a show right i
mean come on yo
let's get the energy levels up come on
today's episode yeah today's episode is
sponsored by bluechu
upstart and this new sponsor who i need
to play apparently this video for
uh so here's our our newest sponsor hi
hope you guys please support our
sponsors
hi i'm dick tips with mission park
funeral chapels and cemeteries
this is a cremation urn and did you know
that most funeral homes don't even own
their own crematory and they have to
outsource the cremation process
but at mission park we do own the
crematory and when you entrust your
loved ones to us
they never leave our care custody and
control
so for over 100 years families like
yours have been trusting mission park
and at mission park it's our mission to
care
yeah it's just a gag because his name is
dick tips
if your name was dick tips i mean his
name is probably richard right like
you could buy rich you could go by
richard no it's a choice
but he went he chose to be dick tips and
we love that
we love that apparently when zach
started doing some research to see if
this was like not a gag
like a tim and eric gag i didn't mean to
expose poor dick dips but apparently he
got suited for losing a body
i'm dick tip that goes that contradicts
the guarantee he made in that video
illicitly says that
yeah your loved ones will never leave
his custody dick tips lost a body
couple couple sues for eight million
dollars is that can you
i mean come on it's a dead body how much
are we really valuing it at
i'm dick tiff eight million seems steep
dick claims he's completely innocent and
that uh the couples
actually stole the body back they stole
the body back for what purpose
uh that well it's just that that's what
we're doing
we're in a whole dick tip or conspiracy
hole
here's the girl she lost oh that's sad
she's really oh that's sad
way too young robert dick tips here the
company through
its owner robert dick tips
has denied wrongdoing and accused bill
and his
ex-boyfriend of stealing the body
so where's this body now i'm just
intrigued
what did dick tips do with this body
anyway if you guys are looking to
cremate a loved one
in the san antonio area mission park i'm
dick tips with mission park funeral
chapels and cemeteries this is a
cremation urn and did you know that most
funeral homes don't even own their own
cream
and they have to outsource the cremation
process oh
[Music]
okay we burn our own bodies yeah
anyway i'm out on dick tips thank you
dick tips that's our new sponsor
everybody
not lost a body hey he could be like hey
i'm dick tips and i've only lost
one body in my whole 100 years of
service
they've been up in 100 years other
announcement i wanted to make at the top
of the show
is that jeremy aka the quartering
listen guys i just want to please tell
everybody
you tweeted this out and i think it's
time that we
all leave poor jeremy the quartering
alone he said
yes i pissed in my unfinished basement
drain
and i make zero apologies for it there
got that one out of the way so when it's
two oh i guess that's me
his 200 iq followers stopped by to
defend their leader
i don't even i mean i guess it's a fair
assumption it's about you but
what was the context of this i don't
know that i can open that i mean
a lot of people know he peed in his
basement i mean it's like a world it's
like the one known
fact that we all know about the
quartering i'm glad he admitted though
because there was there was some dispute
about it
so i would like to just please tell
everyone to please leave the
quartering on twitter at the quartering
on twitter alone about peeing in the
basement
my wife went out for pizza without me
yeah
and so i get it it's just
it's upsetting i g there's no telling
what i would do if my wife went out to
movies without me
i'd pee all over the [ __ ] house in my
basement i mean he's the saint bikers
aaron
i'd be all over the [ __ ] place so
anyway jeremy i'm sorry but thank you
for coming clean
and that's about it thank you thank you
thank you peace and love
now guys on to the main scoop here
ah james charles
oh no um
this james charles story is like he
apologized
he admitted to sexting two minors but
there's so much
more and there's so much more coming out
and even when you go to his apology
video which i'll pull up right now
there are he has way too many people
still supporting him
and liking his video hi sisters james
charles here and welcome back
he's more he's just a predator i mean
pedophile
he's not trying to [ __ ] like
eight-year-olds right
yeah i think predator is a more accurate
description than pedophile it's got a
significant
more dislikes that's interesting but he
says 260 000 people are like
oh i forgot to play that hold on let me
play this
what
[Music]
yeah yeah
that's what he says every time he gets a
new picture in the dms
wow so
you know he's still working with his
biggest partner morphy
who has refused to even make comment on
the situation
and there's still banners on their
website
dedicated to the greatness of james
charles so
he doesn't seem at risk of of being
cancelled
but what we have in our midst here as
i've i've um
as i've you know pressed before is a
legitimate
bona fide proven predator okay
yeah that's the uh
the special sexy crimes unit
right good calls out
you know since he let me let me
let me put this let me put this in
context okay
16 boys have made allegations against
james
i mean he's almost hitting bill cosby
numbers at this point bill cosby was
hitting what like 5 50.
i mean that's over like his whole bill
cosby is like 80. i mean james is like
how he's in his 20s and he's already hit
baton
16. i mean this guy's racking like major
league numbers
wait for this though 10 of the 16 are
miners
home run baby major league numbers dude
you know crazy
uh it's gross oh yeah
and there's also allegations of him like
her sexually harassing fans and stuff
i feel like we can't it's too much
criminality here to just sit aside
let it slide and be like okay he made
the thing we made the videos about him
he made the apology
i don't think that we should just let
this slide without addressing
the the uh torrent
of allegations that keep accumulating
while he's still
being accepted by the majority of people
on the
on the platform i can't do it i'm
desperate
right he is desperate did you forget
about that defense
yeah maybe i'll cancel this video
you know since he made his apology video
on april 1st
eight new accusers five of which were
miners came out
this is the special sv svo
this is i believe all of the law and
orders use that sound actually
but that the svu would be appropriate
for james
this is the svu there's going to be an
episode of james charles svu i'm
certain of it oh you're probably right
because they
they base all of their stuff off of real
events bro i
guarantee it i can't wait for that oh
that'll be good so i want to go over
each one of these
but before i do i want to give a shout
out to my boy d'angelo walls who always
always has a good take on things
you know d'angelo made that like uh the
moment shane dawson's career
ended that was like
kind of a big deal has like 20 million
views but you guys probably all know
d'angelo
anyway he said this about james charles
if he was going to make a video on him
or not
so imagine imagine just go through this
exercise with me for a second and y'all
might understand why i'm not making a
video about this
imagine you have a 14 year old brother
or a brother younger than you maybe
you're 14
maybe you have a 12 year old brother
okay right a random
random 21 year old man has been
exchanging
pornography with your kid brother
gets caught for this online and then
goes online
claims that he didn't understand what he
was doing claims he didn't know his age
claims that he's a bit of a victim
because he was just desperate and has
trouble dating
and gets 125 000 likes and gets to
continue posting
and everyone's just going to move on
because he quote unquote addressed it
as extreme as that is that is what
happened
there's no difference between the words
i just said
and what we just watched and that is why
i am just like
i've legitimately had it like i cannot
continue making like 45 minute videos
where i just take every single thing we
talk about what led up to this
because this is just getting to be so
much more extreme than like
randomly internet things i disagree with
a little bit
but i think are funny there's no growth
from any normal person to gain from this
there's no benefit to hearing or
learning about this it's just disgusting
and all of these people need to
just legitimately have their platforms
removed
i am okay with the platforming if the
platform is used to harm children
you heard it here first folks i set the
d word and i think
i legitimately think like any person
is probably okay with d platforming if
the platform is specifically the tool
that enables
children to be hurt but yeah
overall this is just disgusting and it
makes i'm gonna be honest with you as
well
it makes me angry that i have a whole
video
on my channel with what seven
eight million views that kind of
kind of makes james charles seem like
he's in a positive light
again i'm not going to start blaming
myself for that because i look
anyway yeah
it's crazy this this goes beyond normal
goofs that we've been dealing with this
is this is a predator right here
and he's going to continue to make
videos and he's going to continue to
pray on children
and you know
at what it makes me wonder you know like
take
does tik tok at what point have a
responsibility
or even youtube
is it is there some like superior
responsibility of these platforms when
someone's using it
literally to harm children
you know i mean i saw instagram recently
they um implemented a new policy where
if you're over 18 you can't message
minors you can't message people under 18
it's kind of interesting so that's good
that they're
not at least they're doing something
about it but tick tock seems to be
not only removing criticism of james as
bullying
but you know tick tock does this really
disturbing thing i don't know if you
guys have noticed it
but when i'm scrolling on my feed
they'll show people on my feed that
follow me just random followers
that has that's not an interesting video
or has no business being on my feed
they're just trying to get me engaged
with my fans i guess and so they'll show
me
random uh like
two follower accounts that follows me
and sometimes it's like
children it's like it's
that [ __ ] is cr have you guys seen that
phenomenon yeah yeah that's
it's a newer feature in the west it
creeps me out i don't like it i
hate it and then oh and also it even
encouraged you it says follow
gives you like a big prompt that says
like oh follow this person they're your
fan or something
and it shows you that they follow
similar people right they're like
they're not just a fan they're a super
fan so it's almost like they've got
these
tools that
would even help enable someone like
james what what do
what is someone with millions of
followers on tick tock need help
following
fans random fans it's just odd
and weird and creepy my for you page and
explore page are
not dating apps well
aren't they anyway it is really sad and
depressing and it's like dude i just i
really hope someone presses charges
it's not funny let's see 16 boys have
made accusations
10 of them miners 10
10 minor sextings five have come forward
since his apology
i've got a highlight of all of them here
so here i've got so fourth
this kid was 14 a b yeah
the very first one before in uh july
yeah reported to be 14.
what i didn't know he was sexting a 14
year old
yo whoa the youngest i heard of was 16.
sister oh
yo this guy is sexting 14 year olds
okay let me pull this one up because i
am not familiar with it
you know it's funny i think when this
kid came out i kind of do remember this
everyone was like oh this is just a
cloud chaser because this was like the
first kid that came out against him
and you know everyone's like clown
chasing piece of [ __ ]
14 year old
ethan claims let's see ethan
claims that he was sending and
soliciting
explicit images on snapchat
he says he's tick-tock boy james
mentioned what the [ __ ]
ethan claims he's tick-tock boy james
mentions and what
what does his words mean ethan claims
he's tick-tock boy james mentions oh he
mentioned him
no the kid he wanted to fly out
are you serious is that what it means he
wanted to fly a 14 year old boy out
yeah really sad he's implying yeah that
was the one that was talked about on
impulsive bro i
can't do this
okay let's listen
wow yeah going back now and reviewing
this from the beginning is
kind of a lot
the reason why i'm here today is because
ethan didn't feel comfortable oh why are
we going so fast he's like sped up
filming this alone after numerous
threats made to him by james charles all
right so about a couple months ago back
in march too
um it's a little sped up there for you
huh yeah
those could just get right through it
one of my homeboys around james i was
live
and you're like like joining this like
let's just troll them like we're just
playing why is it going so fast
i don't know is there something wrong
with the video or is it just like that
he's trying to get into twitter limits
is that it he's trying to get in the
twitter limit to a minute
yeah oh all right
let's just listen on double speed the
original ones are
not on youtube anymore it's been removed
i thought it was like yo
i got this one i wasn't thinking
anything other than i said all right i'm
gonna dm him so i deem him and um
i guess the next day he responds and he
tells me why do you keep texting me i
was like
what i don't keep texting you like what
are you talking about and he just kind
of knows this up there because i see
like a picture back at me i guess i
don't know he finds me attractive or
whatever i don't know what i don't know
what he was hiding in his brain going on
he asked me what my age was and i told
him
i thought i was 14 years old and he told
me i was very young and i said yeah and
he said
snapchat because i feel more comfortable
talking on there and so i said okay
let's do it like
and i mean bro come on like i that story
adds up
he goes i'm 14 and james says add me on
snapchat
nah guys wow sister
it's so interesting because this was the
first story that everybody dismissed
and now coming back to it it lines up
with everything
that we know he was soliciting a [ __ ]
14 year old chris hanson step the [ __ ]
in here
that's straight up chris hansen age
that's the age that they pretend to be
on
date on [ __ ] catch a predator i'm
chris hanson with dateline nbc
14. that's like prime
predator age
there ain't no whoop this is what
this is what james says when he thinks
he's about to snap with a 14 year old
yeah yeah yeah and then this is what he
says when it's chris hanson
when it's chris hanson he goes
like no no is that funny or not
this is serious matters though it's not
joke dan please
i like to make love me not knowing
anything like i just think that's cool
like james charles like
18 17 million followers like once you're
out of my snap like not even in the
cloud way like i'm saying like that's
dope like an influencer like
everybody knows who he is pretty much i
like that yeah you don't need to explain
yourself it's obvious you're like okay
this is interesting
cool mega celeb wants to talk to me like
totally makes sense so i thought i was
cool and
he just started getting a little too
comfortable with me and just pushing it
over the limits knowing i was underage
and
i started talking to him about it he
didn't really believe it until he he saw
it with his own eyes james charles being
so pushy and just making me feel
uncomfortable to the max
and i honestly like he was like i guess
he was trying to get me into thinking i
was bisexual he gave whatever he wants
to
whatever y'all want to call it but he
was asking me some news and he kept
wanting me to go to la and he kept
sending me news and i kept
just sending me a picture back i didn't
respond just listen to that picture back
to me and he would leave it on open and
it's not me like a few hours later
sending me another picture of his like
ass you know i'm just gonna say like it
was just it was just it made me feel
super uncomfortable and so um
yeah like honestly like i'm not making
this video to cancel them i'm just
trying to help others out there because
there's a lot of kids
that are my age i think it's awesome
that james charles is actually item on
snapchat but in reality he's trying to
he's trying to make you think that you
are something you're not and i don't
want to happen to anybody else and to
all the parents and everybody watching
this video
i'm trying to help you out for the
future with your kids and to make sure
always like
stay in touch like ask them like check
their phones whatever you want to do
y'all cause like there's people like
james is the chocolate editor
oh i think it is you asked him how long
you were when he told you he was 14
years old you still continue to try to
force yourself on a minor okay a little
kid so my thing is like i don't know i
don't think that's cool
yo this guy's story is one trillion
percent true
allegedly but i'm just saying like
as this was the first accusation i think
a lot of people were like
okay dude you know what i mean um
i think uh when when was this posted
summer of 2020 july 27
2020. so if i recall
the the kind of pendulum swing of like
hating james charles had swung
way back in his favor because that
wasn't that long after he had made
his kind of like rebuttal to the whole
snap yeah
tata right which was um
one of her accusations was about this
kind of stuff and he had kind of
you know at the time seemingly shut all
that down
that's right so people yeah people were
in james's corner here
right bro i can't believe he was he
would actually be hitting on a 14 year
old
that is so disturbing can you guys
please and
like why is the fbi not taking his hard
drive and phone this kid says he's been
sending him dick like literally was
sending him pictures of his nude body
what is with snapchat snap now snapchat
needs to get its [ __ ] together bro
snapchat is the sh is the predator's
playground
wow sister it's not crazy
bro i don't even have snapchat i don't
even know a race snapchat
i'm [ __ ] what is a snapchat
even having that do you guys have
snapchat
i do of course a b does maybe not not
like that you're a predator you're just
like the social media guy
i was gonna say you spend time on
snapchat what goes on there other than
uh
sexual assault um no i haven't as much
recently but i used to be on snapchat i
used to post a snapchat every day
but then after instagram has stories i
kind of just post my instagram stories
on snapchat
sometimes my closer friends from back
home on snapchat
i see yeah go ahead zach
i just i think it's a dumb [ __ ] app
yeah it sucks
i never understood the concepts of
something erasing i
always find that so appealing it's like
i make a post and then it goes away
so i never even engage with it i was
like that sounds horrible
but then it makes sense james charles is
like oh you posted it goes away
so i post my dick pic and then all of a
sudden
the fbi can't find it but it's like
meanwhile at snapchat headquarters you
know they got receipts
can we please sister get a [ __ ]
bro please can we get a search warrant
for snapchat hard drives
imagine the [ __ ] they would find in
james charles outgoing snaps
they really should
i'm having a hard time getting over the
fact this kid is 14 like wow
holy [ __ ]
the next one came out only a month later
or no july
august two months later a 17 year old
september 25th uh
tick tock accused james of sliding into
his dms and then ghosting him james
claims it took dr slitted to his dms
no the kid the kid wanted to [ __ ] me
your honor
let's see i'm gonna look at the minor
ones 17
or so let me go in order actually
january 25th
this is a few months later
so now we're in this year 2021.
james exposed for allegedly sending
unsolicited nudes and trying to pressure
straighten into having
sexual relations with him that's just
like a hobby man that's like
what he does in his free time like this
is james charles full-time [ __ ] job
uh it's gross he's trying to get dick
pics from guys like what
trying to like what bruh
i'd like to see the time you know
there's like a chart and time spent on
your phone on like social media
you guys got a full-time [ __ ] job
trying to get little pictures of kids of
kids penises
peace and love of course jared fogle
that is so true
that's fine just bleep it'll be funny
shout out to uh are we rolling or no
yeah
i just hear you typing like so loud
because i'm i'm having to put a bunch of
notes because half of what you're saying
i'm gonna have to edit out
thanks dan all right um
shout out to jared fogle by the way
i have a feeling they would have a lot
to talk about over a few
sandwiches
let's go back in order so this is when
he really ramps it up right
so that was january february the next
month he's
found hitting on a 17 year old boy
james was accused by a second underage
boy of allegedly having inappropriate
interactions
um this all comes from deaf noodles by
the way who's
done a great job of like
are the archiving all this legend having
inappropriate interaction well the 17
year old said nothing sexual happened he
lies james
continued to flirt with him after he
told him he was 17. we all
we all know after this point is true hey
i introduced myself and said i was 17 in
a photo
he continued to flirt and said he
thought i was a catfish
mm-hmm what was on the agenda tonight
yeah we know it was on the agenda
uh next up march 10 the next month
there's only a couple weeks later
you know the people who come forward is
probably a small percentage of the
amount of people he's actually talking
to right
so two weeks later 16 year old boy comes
forward
accusing james of allegedly sending him
nudes you can only imagine how much
is actually going on behind the scenes
um this poor kid's tick tock got erased
that's what i'm saying with tick tock
like
um was this this was actually the one i
think that
like was the big story that happened
recently right
or was that later um i believe it was a
little later
okay yeah so
16 year old james charles trying to uh
ex uh let's see
this guy says he should be in jail
i agree people accuse me of lying
that's why the cops are looking into
their computer system
okay whatever is there any receipts from
this one uh
maybe other than that this guy's just
saying it happened
um a lot of this guy's receipts were
wiped and they were wiped from death
noodles account as well
like yeah like twitter i believe gave
death noodles a band i believe was on
this one oh
okay so like this is like this weird
paradox
like i noticed the 14 year old kids
video got removed
and someone's got to figure this out
because they go oh it's change
it's child endangerment we have to
remove it but like how are these kids
supposed to [ __ ] talk about the fact
that there's this predator
who's using their platforms to target
kids
it doesn't make any sense i'm not
physically attracted to
older guys you know what i mean
it's it's so stupid sometimes these
[ __ ] platforms like
like look at this the 14 year old kid we
we watched
the first one his enough feeling this
video was removed for violating terms
or this terms of service like i'm sorry
what
what terms of service exactly do you
violate you didn't even describe
anything
this is important [ __ ] that should be
out there in the [ __ ] world and
youtube is like protecting james charles
tick tock on the other should be they
should be investigated bro they're like
enabling him
it's weird the next one has a lot of
receipts
marks um let's see in february another
one the next day
the next day james allegedly pressured a
fan to send him explicit photos this one
was not underage
but like this alone is a scandal right
just pressuring your fans
[ __ ] as you can see conversation this
all happened during the whole tacky
scandal
um i actually reached out to him because
i felt bad for him as you can see he
asked me for my snap right here
anyways let me get that snapchat buddy
about to get assaulted everybody
watching this do not add celebrities on
chat
snapchat i promise you bad things are
about to happen to you
does anything good happen on snapchat
no i don't think so
we have a family chat it's nice oh you
do yeah pictures and videos of my nieces
but that's pretty much it
oh good things happen on snapchat mm-hmm
don't add james charles without family
chat we'll get weird
real quick
as you can see right here at this point
he messaged me right away as you can see
so as you guys can see uh we did develop
a streak i know three isn't a lot but it
does show to prove that we were
snapchatting each other back and forth
for a bit
and at this time we were actually on
really good terms i did not think he was
gonna do anything stupid
so anyways we started talking again at
three in the morning and we were
snapping each other
i sent him a shirtless picture and it
was literally just me working out at
home
if you know me i literally post that
[ __ ] on my story all the time it's quite
obvious that he was pressuring me to
sending him photos
after doing what he said he questioned
my confidence alright so as you guys can
see um he's questioning my confidence
because i didn't want to send him a
specific
explicit photo and i just find that very
disgusting like who does that
person yeah one thing we've noticed time
and time again
because there's an apology video he goes
i'm just
the truth is i'm just desperate but what
you actually see in all these receipts
over and over again
is a very um determined
uh pushy character
who will demean you and insult you
and and and and do whatever they can
to get what he wants out of you right
this is not this is not a play to find a
relationship he's being pushy he wants
the photos
he's me i was being reckless he's
manipulating him you know what i mean
this is not about relationships over
here i was telling him i was tired that
it was late but he didn't seem to care
so
obviously me being me i didn't want to
lose the opportunity to talk to him
so i continued to do what he said
anyways i was getting really tired
because it was super late it was almost
four o'clock am and when i told him i
want to sleep he started to make me feel
bad
he even asked me a video call and i said
i didn't want he still proceeded to call
my phone
at this point i got very very anxious
and as you can see i'm literally shaking
in this video because i was so scared
i didn't want to do it so i chose not to
i told him i didn't want to video call
him because i was scared my parents
would walk in he told me to go to the
bathroom this is what he said then he
gave me attitude and he removed me off
snapchat as you can see what pissed me
off the most is how he questioned my
confidence i'm gonna be posting part
three i'm running out of time
yeah that's his mo dude he calls these
guys out
he makes them feel horrible and then
when either he gets what he wants from
them or he doesn't get what they want
from them whenever the interaction's
over he blocks them
does that sound like someone who's
desperate and looking for love
like he says in his apology i really
thought i met someone great
um no this is this is a sick dude who
needs to have his platform removed like
literally cannot continue
so the next one wait we should uh take a
break before we move on oh great
let's give us thanks to our sponsors
talking about upstart folks when it
comes to paying off debt it can often
feel like an uphill battle
high interest rates resulting in minimum
monthly payments keeps you in an
endless cycle of debt but upstart can
help you get ahead
upstart is the fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan all
online
whether it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debts
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple
fixed monthly payment unlike other
lenders upstart looks at more than just
your credit score
like your income and employment history
this means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners
and with a five-minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
between 1000
and uh up to 50 000
you can receive funds as fast as one
business state after accepting your loan
so find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today
when you go to upstart.com h3 that's
upstart.com
h3 don't forget to use our url so you
know
who sent them i'm talking about
upstart.com
h3 loan amount will be determined based
on your credit income and certain other
information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
this episode is sponsored by blue chew
guys it's been a hell of a year and i
feel like i've aged 12 years over this
last 12 months and if you're like me
you're seeing your age
slip away tick tock and guess what else
is slipping away
your ability to get a raging hard on
that's right that's what i'm here to
sell you today folks
blue chew it's time to get spring here
and by spring i mean it's time to get
sprung
you know what i mean blue chew you
offers a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable form
so your immature ass can just chew it
instead of having to swallow it like a
vitamin
i prefer chewables i'm not even gonna
[ __ ] lie i'll eat you that [ __ ] all
day
[Music]
you could put a shot you know what i
mean you could inject it in my neck if
you're gonna make my dick hard
right uh i
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat
all forms of ed erectile dysfunction
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no visit to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations and no
waiting a line at the pharmacy and it
ships right to you to score in discreet
package so your neighbors don't know
that you can't get it up
but they do blue chew knows but your
neighbors won't
but they won't have you probably like
privacy laws and [ __ ]
but don't be embarrassed i mean half is
the best of us you know what i mean
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part
it's all online bluechoo's licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredients and the strength
of the prescription
to get your dick hard enough to cut
diamond
don't like swallowing pills no problem
chew it you [ __ ] baby
that's me they didn't say that blue
chews uh
oh boy they really want me to pronounce
this it's called sildenafil
[Music]
that was actually pretty close yeah they
luckily they phonetically spelled it
blue chews sildenafil and
tablets are chewable bluetooth tablets
are made in the usa and they prepare and
ship direct so it's cheaper than at a
pharmacy
god bless listen you could use the
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety
information a special deal for our
listeners try blue chew
free when you use our promo code h3 at
checkout
and you just pay five bucks for these
chewable
boner inducing but i don't know what
they do but they make your dick card
i don't know the science five dollars
though
promo code h3 go to bluetooth.com promo
code h3
receive your first month free and we
thank you bluechu for sponsoring our
podcast
march 31st we have another 16 year old
love that lots of recipes
oh okay i don't think i don't know if
i've even seen this one oh my god
this is i know that this is a serious
subject
but this [ __ ] tick tock made me laugh
so [ __ ] hard is this one of the like
super speed ones where you can't [ __ ]
tell yourself
it's even better than that let's see
damn it i've been banned from dave and
busters
why duke nukem
wait so this is about a 16 year old okay
let me read the caption here
everything's on screen
do you shave your body now that's all i
needed to see yeah hey
16 year old boy do you shave your body
dude you're free crap dude please he
belongs in prison
gabish thanks
how am i bye to look at all these all
right we can't look at these anyways
we can we're gonna have to blur all of
this do you have a nice body
do you shave your body i'm just laying
here bored and horny hahahahaha
can i get a whomp bomb for that one
can i get a chris hanson sit right over
here please for that one
no don't you take a seat right over
there he says it would literally take
you 30 seconds to send a pic like this
yeah but that he's already implying that
the kids already resisted right
he's like dude it would only take you 30
seconds god
stuff to ban you did you bring condoms
um just take a pic dumbass
he looks kind of crazy
it's that's that like that's that like
that cute predator [ __ ] going on there
yeah you can't be like q and a predator
at the same time you know what i mean
you gotta pick your lane he's a little
spooked just take a pic
dumbass how old were you again 16 that's
fine i flirted with much younger
okay got it you give off
big dick energy low bro you're such a
creep
come pick me up for some road head bro
stop
right now holy [ __ ]
literally perfect i [ __ ] up and then
all of a sudden so what's the duke nukem
sound bite have to do with anything
i don't i think it's a tick tock trend
sound
yeah it is i thought he yeah but yeah
but it's gotta have some context that's
because dave and buster's
well dave and buster's is specifically
for like adults i don't know
i don't get it i don't know busted james
and nuked his career
i i figured um he blocked him or
something
okay here we go one more time let's do
it with the audio let's just give it one
more go
because dan loves it so much
damn it i've been banned from dave and
busters
dude this guy just [ __ ] [ __ ] all over
james
this guy just exposed james so hard in
the time lapse of five
seconds with the duke nuka meme on top
like holy [ __ ]
yeah this is one of the worst ones i've
seen wow wow
that's a 16 year old not cute
not funny people liking james charles
morphy
morphy which we'll talk about later
still working with him no comment from
morphe
[Music]
interestingly um
o.j simpson still works with nike no i'm
kidding speedy like that though
nike sponsoring o.j after like
he's in jail or he never went to jail
but during the trial just do it
oj went to jail oh separately he did go
to jail thank you dad
for saying the world truly for stealing
back his memorabilia or some wild [ __ ]
he's so wild dude armed robbery
armed robberies showed up uh with a gun
and demanded a bunch of uh what in his
view with stolen
goods stolen from him really it was this
man trophy
i'm not mistaken something like that i i
forget the details
anyway it's like sponsoring o.j simpson
while he's in prison
that's the equivalent of morphe keeping
james charles on their
roster hey twitterworld just do it
what is james charles uh thing he says
don't blend don't blend in
yes
a twitter world hi sisters
remember not to blend try not to blend
in with the 16 year old boys
bro he's good oh god i hope he goes to
prison
i mean
that one's great that one that one's up
there with the 14 year old woman that
shocked the hell out of me i'm not even
gonna lie
same day he had another accusation the
same [ __ ] day
yes march 31st was a big day for james
charles
this guy all the while still just
cruising along making videos everyone's
happy
james is making him ton of money with
those little [ __ ] makeup kits
has he made any content or publish any
content since his apology video
has gone radio silent he's gone radio
silent i think
right yeah said he was taking a break in
the video i mean it hasn't been that
long
but in this video he's like i'll be back
guys i just wanted to
say you know put it all out there so we
can learn
i'll be back in 10 to 15. yeah ten
exactly
hopefully longer tend to life
hopefully he's jails jailmates with matt
gates they'll have a lot to talk about
okay the same [ __ ] day james charles
gets exposed for allegedly soliciting
and paying for nudes what he's offering
people money now
from a fan james allegedly said
shut up and send stuff and you'll get
money if you take good pics and videos
man i don't know to me but that sounds
pretty romantic
that sounds like a guy who's just
desperate for love
desperate for [ __ ] i like it peace let's
get glam
bro what the [ __ ] okay is this gonna be
another duke nuka meme
why are these videos all so short oh
damn
i just got a snapchat invite from james
charles
hi guys yes i did that why are y'all
gonna do
packages in like the weirdest
meme they are making the same [ __ ]
face it's like
why do they all make the like smug like
half smile face
it's i don't the fbi would have
arrested james charles like [ __ ]
years ago if these kids would just make
like although at the same time you look
at what the 14 year old did and it got
removed by youtube you know what i mean
like he did it the right way i suppose
and youtube is trying to get around the
algorithm or something
right you have to fool the adults
like if you're if you're a grown if you
work at the fbi watch this imagine
taking any info
yes i did that and you would do it too
for a change i was an employee
and i was going to get employee of the
month and nothing period hi guys
actually that me makes sense at least
all right let's see what this
this loving conversation was like he
says
devin shut up and send stuff and you'll
get money
if you take good pics and videos you're
being rude i'm sorry a no-go
wow pretty mature response from him
we'd love to see it
and then he's saying hello oh here's the
receipts
hello good only 40 bucks james come on
pony up
he gave him a hundy 40 50 and
what looks like 30 40. bro what the [ __ ]
what he's sending money to fans to send
news you guys do you
understand what we're seeing here and
he's flipping him off too
he's like doing some daddy dom [ __ ] on
him
bro i can't do this
i know youtube doesn't like it but this
deserves all to be
exposed in the daylight so
it's got to be seen i mean the depth of
this is just so disturbing
can i get a womp bomb for our
monetization
can i get a whomp womp womp for our uh
age restriction
but can i get a yeah yeah for being
important
thank you sometimes you just gotta do it
what's right
so since james apology video on april
1st there have been
um seven new accusers four of which
were minors
that's more than 50 that's right
here comes the apology video of him
saying i'm desperate sisters
i was looking for love in all the wrong
places
i'm actively searching for younger
people to be in a relationship with
and basically just kind of makes himself
the vic you guys all seen it
well the next day
the very next day april 1st was the day
of the apology
april 2 new accusation
james charles
fan exposes james for allegedly
harassing him for nudes even after
he told james he was straight and not
interested james said in a snap you're a
huge dick let me see
daddy he's 18 so
but again remember
this even alone is like really creepy
daddy daddy please don't go please don't
go
i love you so i love you so oh please
another great meme format that is just
way
unnecessary
here let me mute it there uh last thing
you need
okay so you you you you you you you you
you you you you
you you you
you you he sends them all the same
pictures with the heart on the eyes and
stuff
hey you you're a huge dick let me see it
daddy
all years daddy i want to see more of
you
daddy chill bro i can't do this
that's the day afterwards that's the
next day bro
daddy
this is the bit this is maybe the
biggest
this is potentially the biggest most
heinous
um outreaching a scandal in youtube
history
i don't think we've ever seen anything
like this just
the gravity the ages the the amount
um and the size of the creator involved
too i mean
i mean james is he's like the bit one of
the biggest tick tock accounts in the
world
one of the biggest on youtube right he's
he's so well connected
with like all these celebrities the
kardashians and [ __ ]
one day later the next day a 16 year old
comes out against james charles
he's got oh this is the
oh
oh this is the one about the tall yeah
we've talked so this was the one we've
talked about
uh i'm sorry for some reason some of the
links are
going to the top of the thread rather
than the specific this is the one though
i think
this was a 15 year old one he returns
this was the guy who's like six
seven or something we talked about on
the podcast
this was the one that really lit james
ass up
and also in a weird meme format let's
see what it is
[Music]
there's like so much information that 10
seconds you got to fool the
adults though otherwise they'll delete
it
yeah i've looked at this one anyway 16
you know
james tried to say he didn't know his
age which was blatantly [ __ ]
ridiculously obvious like his age was
everywhere all over his profile
it's like come on bro it's ridiculous
give me a break same day this is crazy
bro
the same day
james star allegedly tried to shoot his
shot with an english singer-songwriter
alfie
templeman who was underage at the time
of the shot that he allegedly took so
apparently he's famous
how could he possibly say he didn't know
his age james charles try to shoot a
shot with an english singer songwriter
who's apparently famous so obviously you
knew he was underage at the time
he's someone at him wait did james
charles try to shoot his shot with you
last year yeah
it's not much but it is something that
is a you
you fbi detectives be like yeah
bro i swear to god somebody better be
investigating this
right like somebody has got to be
investigating this at this point
pretty likely that pretty likely that
he's got to have
yeah there's got to be an open case on
this i know these investigations take a
while and they interview a lot of people
so it's not like
not expecting anything to happen right
away but i just pray to god
that he is being investigated i'm chris
hanson with dateline nbc
someone a little more official than that
so this by the way which i totally
forgot too
uh james did a tick tock bachelor
in january 2020 um
which has not aged gracefully in
consideration of everything dan can you
on me james here i can't believe i'm
making this video right now but i feel
like this can't hurt and i
don't think it'll turn into a scandal
either so i guess here it goes nothing
i made one major observation after that
i'm going to take a few weeks ago and
that is that this app
is pretty much a dating app let's be
wrong everyone on here
no it's not what what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
how is tick tock a dating app
it's just the prince it's the it's the
praying grounds for you
dude dude he straight up just was like
hey guys everything in that whole intro
hey guys i'm looking for as much young
dick as i could possibly find
send me your applications and then add
me on snapchat
i fall into that second group of people
surprise surprise in 2020 however
i'm trying to change that okay i'm
trying to put myself out there a little
bit more and i want to get wiped up
so i want to play tick tock bachelor
my name is james charles i'm 20 years
old and i am five times
in los angeles california and i am a
beauty youtuber so sometimes i look
pretty and
when i don't look pretty i have a pretty
fun personality to make up for it
i'm a very hard worker but in my free
time i like horror movies escape rooms
singing with friends i don't think
any you'd only think you do in your free
time is snap miners
from what i can tell that's a lie eating
at new restaurants and also i have fun
nails for back scratching and cuddling
if those things are interested leave me
a comment down below or i guess do it
this video
oh my god what have i done
bro so creepy so creepy i love this part
i love this part here grab this sack
throughout this video
oh my god what have i done oh my god
what have i done
helpful also the part where he says
let's face it this is a dating app
shut up james you [ __ ] creep
it's 14 let's not forget he texted a 14
year old
damn sexted and finally the most recent
one came out
two days ago these are these are still
coming in he says that james slidens his
dmz was very demanding something we've
seen
he says he lost interest in once he grew
facial hair
hmm that kind of adds up with his
james here i can't believe i'm making
this video right now but i feel like
this
can't hurt and i don't think it'll turn
into a scandal either so i guess here it
goes nothing
i made one major observation after
downloading tech talk a few weeks ago
and that is that this app is pretty much
a dating app
let's be real and then this is the only
screen
let's see hey saw your duet to my video
wanted to say you're handsome and should
tell me more about yourself
i add you on snap oh [ __ ] oh oh
that's where it all goes down boy no
receipts the only screenshot i have
because
after we started talking on snap i
wasn't like the other boys where i was
like taking a picture off a different
device
i do want to say for the record like i
definitely was into him like i was the
one who do edit the video
i wanted to talk to him but i changed my
mind like i just didn't like the way he
was speaking to me like
demanding [ __ ] control like i don't know
just didn't vibe with me i also do want
to mention this was like a year ago
a lot happens in a year people do change
i'm not saying
he changed or anything but i don't think
any of us relates to who we are like a
year ago
another thing is we never talked about
my age like at the time i definitely did
look young i was legal
i was 21 at the time don't worry but
once i started growing up my facial hair
i don't know if this has any correlation
we kind of stopped talking does because
i don't know there he is
there's a guy that doesn't open up his
ass cheeks in the shower to let the
water in
just imagine how oh that okay i was
wondering
so after he made that he says message me
on snap stinky that ass could be
message me now like what the [ __ ]
bro you are such a pathetic [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
message me back on snap now
my for you page and explore page are not
here you go
a guy who he was who was actually
interested in him
and he ghosted him once he grew a
[ __ ] mustache because he looked too
old
sister all right
that's that eh so now i'm moving on to
the people that are continuing to enable
and monetize james charles who are
allowing him to have a career and a
future really on this platform
talking primarily of course about morphe
morphe even on as recently as april 3rd
um after james apology and everything
his admission really his confession i
should call it
posted a [ __ ] promotion for his
palette
ex x james
charles palette let's get that let's get
that hashtag training let's get
excitement guys
the but this money you know how they say
like uh this money will directly go to
help
save the planet or whatever turn your
charity this money will directly go to
help
kids get preyed upon oh
i'd love to support that friend this
money will directly be used to harm
children
great
morphe enabling child predators
we'd love to see it so that was recent
they got backlash and then okay so
they got backlash people like why are
you promoting james's palette
what did they do did they remove it from
the website nah they just removed the
hashtag
those pigments be popping they just
blend they just uh
they just removed the hashtag but it's
still up on the website
they're
james charles palette on morphe morphe
directly supporting
the harm of children since nineteen
friday
and i oops
um insider put out an article about
james and morphy's relationship
apparently they've been trying to reach
out to them for comment
and morph has declined to uh comment on
this
but one thing they have not declined to
do
is remove james charles from their
website
let's give a round of applause to morph
people remember
remember unleash your inner artist baby
but can i get a let's see what we got
here
if you go to morph dot com slash pages
james charles we're going to unleash our
artist in fact it's even listed here if
you go to
let's see brands featured brands i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on with this
x morphe x james charles right here baby
let's go
yeah ten miners
let's see if we can get the palette we
can get the brushes
we love that so much talent
so much talent wow
yeah i would say his greatest talent is
getting miners to send him pictures of
their penis on snapchat
and he's really good at makeup so that's
saying a lot
like if you consider how good he is at
makeup
so they have not addressed
it they are just loving james charles
products
um it's not the first time they found oh
this is interesting morphe has found
itself in criticism before
linked to an influencer they cut ties
with jeffree star
what did jeffrey star shane dawson even
do compared to this
they cut ties with jeffree star and
shane dawson who by the way are saints
compared to this i mean
let's be real right can i say that
maybe let's not say they're saints
but let's say they're not ready to serve
time in prison
james charles yeah like
why are we making the exception for
james
so who's the owner of morph did you guys
find any information about that
no we looked into it they talked to um
some people were talking about like
future collabs and other companies but
specifically like the uh another
influencer or another makeup artist
kevin james
uh bennett was talking about how morphe
was covering up for him
um but i looked into it and there's not
too much on it publicly at least
not as of now let's talk about william
ford who's the owner of gentr
general atlantic who is the majority
owner of morphe he's a big boy he's got
34 billion in accents under his
management he's crushing it
um philanthropy
rockefeller uh oh
i don't know what i said is that part of
the conspiracy thing
the uh it used to be well the
rockefellers
they've sort of they've they've fallen
out of the conspiracy i mean they they
certainly still are involved in some
conspiracy theories
their star has faded a little bit in
favor of not in my heart
soros is and the koch brothers and you
know those type of people
well anyway um i just want
william e ford to know that he is
funding uh
child predator uh every dollar of the
james charles morphe
brand goes to uh uh harming children
shout out to him because nobody seems to
be doing anything about it in that
company which is really incredible
so maybe this guy will [ __ ] know
something about it
anyway that's that right
thank you with peace and love peace and
love
[Music]
that was not a fun segment
but i think it's important to lay out it
the entirety the gravity of
of of all of this is truly [ __ ]
remarkable
i mean this this is a man who's running
major numbers
well let's let's clean our palette
before we move on
with one final video
[Music]
that is literally a paralysis demon
can you imagine you're paralyzed you're
stuck you're almost weird like
fish mouth pale
the paleness it looks like from the
from the hp lovecraft story oh yeah
it's like half he reminds me i've
transformed into a fish man
the guy with the eyes on his hands oh
from pan's labyrinth
something like that you're paralyzed you
can't move
you're just staring at james charles
going yeah yeah yeah
you sure that's what hell is that's
something i'm repeating
he's out there guys let's go and get him
fbi open up
yeah it's funny you know chris
chris hanson did this whole thing about
like uh that's his name
the youtuber that everyone thought was
yeah onision
shane jeffree star all these people that
have like all these crazy accusations
against them
this
this makes them all look like child
split they ain't
[ __ ] compared to james charles
this is crazy numbers brah
he's the kobe bryant i know you guys
don't like me to say that but
what would you rather me say he's the um
jordan his name is kobe bryant right
with the t the t is silent isn't it
kobe bryant i never see her anyone say
go oh walk around kobe bryant
i never hear anybody say kobe bryant
really
that's what i hear when everyone says
his name kobe bryant
anyway he's the kobe bryant of uh
gotta really spray that tea out
of uh predator predatory behavior so
shout out to his family
yeah we want to talk about giuliani and
little not sex this is more
definitely more funny yes more light
more funny more light we love this we
love giuliani rudy giuliani as you know
giuliani
um he was trump's lawyer
sort of he is a legend he is
i mean you all saw giuliani everywhere
he was like his lawyer that was just
running around just kind of leaking
[ __ ] black
liquids from his forehead right like
there were many legends
in philadelphia what was it called the
uh four
seasons oh yeah four seasons uh
landscaping shop landscaping
man that was a legendary like week that
all happened within like five days
like that well anyway giuliani has a pod
or show or something called common sense
you know you'd think that common sense
would indicate not having a presidential
press conference
in front of a sex shop and like the
outskirts of philadelphia but anyway
here he is talking about lilznas x new
video
i'm sure he has a lot to say about it
the music video is
is uh uh filled with biblical references
it begins with the
he's reading this whatever he is this
guy
little nas being seduced by the
by the devil in the form of a snake
obviously from genesis right
he's then put on trial and they they
stone him but they're not really stones
and he heads down into hell he's on his
way to
hell right i i guess he gets there and
then he
engages in a this ridiculous
uh really rather ugly
dance i wish he would narrate everything
vulgar
makes it way better
with uh satan yeah and it's a sexual
dance
yeah i don't know how much of it i
should describe except you gotta get it
it's um
you gotta get this
[Music]
uh what would be anal sex whoa
julie he's like i i don't know i want to
put this
mildly in an unoffensive way he [ __ ]
him in the ass
did he i thought they were just lap
dancing was he pounding saying
i think it was just a left dance but
yeah bro you took it way too far
rudy yeah that's a sound bite
he reproduces uh what would be anal sex
come on rudy that didn't happen did it
anal sex what the [ __ ]
how do i put this delicately he uh
[ __ ] all over his [ __ ] ass
rudy your imagination is getting away
with you
anal sex um
and a few more things that are equally
disgusting
and then the culmination of it is he
dethrones
satan and he becomes satan love it
he murders satan actually and he becomes
that sounds good this uh
the video that i'm describing is
available right now on
youtube what is this a promo
on which you cannot get my podcast at
least for a while
oh you got banned that's right
rudy got banned off youtube probably for
the election
yeah so he's like let me get this
straight little nonsense
[ __ ] satan in the ass on youtube and
my ass can't even come here and spread
russian propaganda
anal sex i don't get by the way he just
described it he didn't even criticize it
like what's your criticism of it bro
he literally just described it in like a
really fun way i mean
disgusting i wonder what rudy yeah i
mean
he's basing all of this on you know his
supposed religious beliefs
i don't understand the christian of the
video he went and [ __ ] satan
satan is probably gay if you all hate
gay people so much what is the bible
what does the bible say about uh
[ __ ] your cousin is that cool did he
[ __ ] his cousin
he married his cousin he's married to
his first cousin uh he was
second cousin he's been married multiple
times what does the bible say about
divorce
by the way probably more than it says
about gay people
probably i think stoning death what is
it
but like if i don't understand you hate
satan right you hate gay people
so everybody you hate is having a party
and they're [ __ ]
doing all the [ __ ] you hate and that's
good right that's where it belongs
gay sex with satan belongs in hell this
is all all cosmic entities are lined up
for you why are
they mad about this you know what i mean
is satan not allowed to get a dick in
his ass then who is
will get cancer in the butthole you know
what i mean
he tries to preface it a little bit by
saying oh he talks about the sneakers a
little bit and says that he's they're
pushing it to kids
but still i mean regardless i mean he's
yeah i really want to go [ __ ] satan now
it'll burn and burn and burn yeah these
guys still believe that um
being gay is a choice i think that's the
big disconnect here
do you know how many kids are going to
be playing coming out of your butthole
are going to choose to be gay because of
this video
i saw a really funny analogy how all the
conservatives are going crazy over
little nazak's video
meanwhile there's like highway to hell
and they're all like
hi wait they love that song boy they got
no problem with highway to hell
i wonder if it's because it's not a gay
black man
singing it that shit's more demonic than
anything
right he's a highway to hell he's want
he's going
well you spin those old rock records
backwards i mean there's a theory that
it says like i'm satan hear me six six
six there you go
oh it was the nightstalker's favorite
song wasn't it i think i read that
somewhere
what'd you say the nightstalker used to
be driving around to highway to hell
oh really that's creepy it was ramirez's
favorite song
that's creepy i don't like that rudy
talk about that now that's creepy
i'm canceling highway to hell and i'm
taking that super bowl
can we just cancel ac dc in general oh
[ __ ] you
dude i love ac dc [ __ ] i [ __ ] suck
dude have you listened to their first
few records i've listened to enough
dude aliens look i'm not saying i'm the
biggest ac dc fan but
i mean rock is my fourth time come on
here dude the alien's coming
too okay all right you're not the
[ __ ] only rock god around here you
want to go rock and roll trivia
you want to throw down my forte [ __ ]
massive [ __ ] in hell
that's what i choose to do with my life
okay all i'm saying aliens come down
and they're all explain rock and roll
you give them two records
okay one of them better not be ac dc are
you going to give them you give them the
who live at leads
okay good okay okay and you give them ac
dc highway oh get the [ __ ]
out of here title track dude that's
right have you have you lost that record
through and through
i'm gonna you know what exactly
also here's the thing too about like you
know like in hell right
it's not even satan was forcing the
gayness on him like little nas
they it seems like they're having a
consensual good time right like satan
was kind of into it
and a little it wasn't like he came down
and and then like devil was like i'm
gonna [ __ ] you i'm gonna have gay sex
with you
lil ma's ex made the choice he's you
know what i mean like he's having a good
time rudy
i think he is the one to blame i mean he
kills satan at the end
that's great isn't that great don't you
love that
we love that he's sitting at a chair
rudy how is he gonna [ __ ] him in the ass
satan's [ __ ] him in that well he's
just doing a lap dance come on
i mean you [ __ ] your cousin like dan
said so anal sex
yeah rudy i'm sure has plenty of
knowledge of what goes on in a
strip club so he should and it's a
sexual dance you should recognize that
rudy really [ __ ] his cousin did they
didn't have kids did they
he didn't just [ __ ] her he was married
to her
wow i'm gonna come that's crazy
he's also i think he's been married four
or five times and
several of the marriages fell apart
because he he cheated on them
uh he he constantly cheats um
it's absurd for him to be moralizing
music sexuality
it's just can you imagine cheating can
you imagine [ __ ] rudy giuliani just
wondering i'd rather [ __ ] satan
yeah easy easy joy of the week easy
choice
ten out of ten times that's [ __ ] up
one of the most grotesque
human beings on this planet how does he
get
really people to cheat on him with like
that just seems like
such a task like how do you convince him
to have sex with that thing
he's got money and power yeah you can
you you probably do can you imagine what
his breath smells like
yeah i mean he's disgusting let's not
forget this scene from borah
[Music]
you can give me your phone number and
your address he takes his dick out
i thought he's about to get some success
or he really thought he was going from
interview to dick out
like he was ready like a cadaver look at
him you want to talk about do monica
just laid out like a vampire
he looks like dracula this is still so
absurd
i wish they didn't stop them man i guess
they had
he was worried about the woman yeah it
was about to get really bad
she's an actress dick is coming out it's
time to put a stop to this well he said
he was uh adjusting his pants i believe
it wasn't he was saying you're taking
your dick out you sick cousin [ __ ]
falling on it get it up can we criticize
chris
wait can we criticize cousin [ __ ] is
that like is
i don't know if i'm being offended is
that like something that we need to
normalize or i mean it's not exactly
incest uh it's insensitive to my culture
it's insensitive insensitive to my
culture of
white well i know in some cultures
marrying your cousin is kind of normal
uh but not in rudy's i could tell you
that
[Music]
yeah we down here rudy john only rants
we're like the [ __ ] all cause we'd like
to get as close to legal incest
as legal incest as possible
now take a look at this little nausea
here get a lap dance to satan
that ain't right oh hold on one sec let
me get a divorce real fast
on to my next wife
[Music]
come on here betsy now this is betsy's
my first cousin
we just had sex and made a baby yeah
that makes me her uncle and her cousin
and her brother and boy
being his sister and the mother we're
all so related now take a look at this
little knowledge x here
oh wait we don't like him he's against
god three victories
an abomination boy
that's it that's all i got but pretty
much
everyone who moralizes is the biggest
[ __ ] hypocrite
i don't say that you spent the first
hour of the episode
well rudy i mean these i mean
specifically these religious guys
right like rudy is such a creep bro he's
a little [ __ ] vampire
ghoulie julian anyway he did a really
epic ad read we found
[Laughter]
[Music]
time to take a short break during the
same uh took a break from lola's ex to
sell
old people a scam
you never thought kovit could cost you
your home right no
it just might because cyber crime is up
75
and by far the cyber
most serious cyber crime to worry about
is home title theft that's right that's
a [ __ ] lie
the most serious cyber crime i've never
heard of home title theft
he does this whole scare read on these
old people that watch his [ __ ] i've
never heard of home title theft
i hadn't either and when i googled it
the only result was
this company that he's selling and
multiple articles about how it's a scam
including
on fox news
yeah well it was a local affiliate of
fox news we better take care of them
better shut them up a cyber crime to
worry about is home
title theft that's right that's right
cyber criminals far enough this isn't my
first
audience after our homes and it's easier
than you think
the title documents to our homes uh are
online now no they're not
what we're talking about this is exactly
what the guy's stealing your title
bro this is straight out of like uh
video blocks
hacker dot mov it's just a loan
this gives me mad tom selleck it's just
a loan reverse mortgage vibes
a reverse mortgage loan isn't some kind
of trick to take your hand
i mean at least a reverse mortgage
exists it is real it is a thing
it exists this is a straight-up scam
i mean with peace and love of course
minecraft
the thing is like this shows what who's
left sponsoring rudy
[Music]
it's it's where does it even exist at
this point
he's been banned off of everything where
does he do this
it was just on where did we even find
him
i wonder how much you got paid for this
ad i mean a couple hundred bucks you
know what i mean like
how much could it possibly be worth and
forge is yours
he may have stopped because he was
getting trolled so much but he did do uh
call-ins that
have been good yeah a lot a lot of
pranks
coming in on that all right let's watch
this title insurance if
if i may interrupt real quick i just
checked on my computer that is from
storyblocks
oh no way yeah what is the video of
yeah what is it was just the first
result was it literally cyber crime
hacking and technology crime and dark
room
good awesome it's just alone yeah this
is like the most stock video [ __ ] i ever
seen in my life
and forges your signature on a quick
claim deed stating
you sold your home to him then he takes
out loans on your home
what and he leaves you in debt what
you won't know until late payment or
eviction notices arrive
what insurance doesn't cover you and
neither do common identity theft
programs
no that's why i protect my home with
home
title lock the instant home title lock
detects someone
tampering with my home's title shut it
down
go to home title lock.com
these featured on fox news it was
featured on fox when they wrote an
article about it being a scam
right let's look at this page look at
this landing page this is like
such scam [ __ ] fbi says you may not own
your home
what f what yep what is that statement
15 a month
here's a picture of bill o'reilly so you
know you can trust it
it's just alone with no context
oh lord help me jesus so she's saying
people hack your
title and then they can do a transfer of
title
and then get um and register your
address to see
if you're already a victim oh no then
use code rudy
to receive 30 free days of protection i
mean code
rooting the bank in most
right oh yeah if you have a mortgage
there's a zero percent chance of this
ever happening to you
no [ __ ] chance i was thinking
somebody used code rudy
if you own your home but these people
are like 80 they're
they're their title's not online it's
probably in their [ __ ] like safety
deposit box
right but also a title doesn't is
a piece of paper it's registered with
the city you can't just sign
a house away like you have there's so
much paperwork involved with
with buying and selling property it's
not just like putting your signature on
a [ __ ] e-document and then
it's just not how it works anal sex
well i'm signing up and i'm using code
rudy
i'd frankly rather buy james charles
morphe palette than this
and you know you'll never [ __ ] cancel
that [ __ ] they'll charge you to the day
you die
fifteen dollars every month home so you
just cancel the credit card
here's an article on fox news about how
it's a scam
title luck insurance is a waste of your
money boom done
it's used by people like bill o'reilly
anyway [ __ ] brudy giuliani he's a ghoul
a reverse mortgage loan isn't some kind
of trick to take your home
all right how long we've been going dan
let's do something
let's do should we do miss connections
let's put let's let's
lighten it up here sure yeah i like that
okay ian you lead the way on this one
uh okay yeah um i was thinking of
starting a new ongoing segment called
sort by new
it's like one of my favorite things to
do is going on weird sites and things
and then sorting by new instead of top
you see the weird [ __ ] that's where all
the weird and wild stuff is
right so today we're going to sort by a
new on the craigslist missed connections
affection these are all posted within
the last two or three days
in the la miss connections uh page
which is always especially spicy yeah
l.a craigslist you didn't have to go you
didn't have to fish deep for these at
all this is just right at the top
it's such a constant ongoing
well well there's a lot of
misconnections out there there's
millions of people crossing by each
other
and um you know there's just lots of
people that are just
like james charles imagine how many
missed connections he has yep millions
of them
i'm sure there's a lot floating around
so uh we each have
two i think that we'll read so if
i don't know whoever wants to go first
dan or
i'll go first i'll hit it off okay this
one is called
taco tuesday west
covina our city
has the best tacos i used to hang out
with my neighbor
and eat tacos i liked hers
because it was dark on the outside
i'm talking about tacos i love to find
someone serving darker
tacos i love mexican tacos and would
love to try
asian talk what the [ __ ]
[Music]
so this is why is he speaking like this
do they have some kind of rules that you
can't be overtly
just like obviously euphemism for
vaginas he's trying to eat he wants to
eat out wait what
excuse me that's vulgar okay next one
let's have a game of basketball again
[Music]
lost dude's number we played one-on-one
behind walmart
there was a basketball court we were
going at and you beat me real good
latino versus black guy it was a good
game
but was more competitive after and we
had fun in the baseball field
scary at night but not really
we had fun in the baseball field scary
at night but not really
he never got this guy's number huh
sounds like they had a hell of a day
i mean sometimes you just run into a
dude
at a basketball court
no these guys they're just they're just
balling out are they not allowed to
make sexual references i don't
understand
is there some kind of rules i thought
craigslist was totally off the rails
[Music]
sometimes you have to have a little more
tact than that ethan
okay who's next
papa jack shoot go ahead zack take it
away
[Music]
[Music]
posted three days ago
male looking for plumber larry from
burbank
northeast los angeles
you're the plumber who worked on my
drain a few times
put yours
you put your snake inside my drain and
release some solution to clear it out
be great and hope i can find you on here
[Music]
i have one more for you need
need asian nutrients
[Music]
nutrients need asian nutrients
san gabriel valley or near oh he's just
looking straight up for asian
nutrients okay
so apparently apparently there are posts
get removed for inappropriate
content which is why people are right
they're having to force to find the most
incredible euphemisms to describe
right sex acts asian nutrients
like eight like ancient chinese uh
remedies
right right respond for more details
be ready to give what you have oh my god
posted three days ago wow
i hope you found that plumber sounds
like he's got a problem with his pipes
i know he's gonna get that take you know
would be funny bit if we actually send
plumbers to these people's house
like a real plumber that doesn't know
yeah at her uni plumbing
who's next hey b hey b why don't you go
ahead
okay uh-oh this one's called
76 gas station cold water you were
getting gas
when i walked by to go to the ralph's
damn
there's a hype they're gonna find each
other for sure
you were getting gas when i walked by oh
dude that's a real lost connection deep
they had a real moment that's a real
love story
true love you got another one maybe
yes this one is called if you're a
latino
with a small tiny package hit me up to
meet my girlfriend
oh that one's not hidden at all
it should be like if you're a latino
with a tiny little skirt
if you're latino with a little burrito
yeah exactly yep there it is
and you want to be able to do more with
my wife
i'm looking for husky big guys with
small packages
wanting to meet one of my girlfriends if
you have a small piece
looking for a little only micro size
give me that you are a fat stocky gordo
with a large package
with a lot wait a large package i
thought he was into no no
sorry thank you dan yeah let me let me
watch you
we want big dick or tiny [ __ ] i gotta
get it right you're seeing the word
gordo that's why yeah especially if you
are a fat stocky gordo
with a little package i love that thank
you dan
so you're not so sure to send the bad
guy with a tiny dick there's someone
for one of his girlfriends you know i
think we may have to flag that one
because
they didn't miss them they're trying to
make a new connection yeah that's a
fresh connection you put these together
ian
it's it's a little dicey i love that
though
just giving love to the big little dick
boys out there i mean respect man they
don't get enough love
that feels good that people are reaching
out to people like me
to [ __ ] their wives or something
no he wants me to [ __ ] his wife he
the message was a little unclear on what
the the intent was but
um ian you want to take once sure
uh we met in trader joe's
we both love their varied and affordably
priced food
we used to hang out spend a little time
together open up a bottle of two buck
chuck
i'm in my mid-thirties you said you're
not a looker
but i like an interesting gal a gal with
a sense of humor
a gal with a little something extra
then you threw my hash browns and
shepherd's pie in your cart
and with a wink you said it's on me
this seems like a trader joe's ad more
than anything
yeah viral marketing i was having
trouble
following the uh the metaphor i was just
there was just a lot of trader joe's
marketing in there
i like how they ran into each other and
the first thing this woman apparently
said to him was you are not a looker
you're ugly as [ __ ] dude
it's a good opening line it disgusts me
it seems like she was more interested in
trader joe's affordable and uh the
variety and affordability of trader
joe's
fine products yeah
i got one more exact you have like some
cool music
some cool
[Music]
there we go yeah
so i'm in the stardust hotel casino
i see three good looking girls playing
blackjack with a dealer this is a friend
of mine
ron i was tired and half drunk but i sat
down anyway because of these three
beauties
and although ron was doing things to
help all of us win
i still lost again i was tired
i decided to leave but as i got up i
said to those three gals that if anyone
would like a night cap
i was in room number so and so
[Music]
with me being drunk and tired i headed
home
to sleep and i heard a knock at my door
with me being drunk i thought it was
room service so i yelled out
no the next day i happened to see ron
he said to me boy oh boy i bet you had
some fun last night
i said huh what do you mean
he said those three girls left my table
about 20 minutes later
and said they're going to my room oh no
i was stunned that i missed the chance
to have some
hot fun this was in the early 90s
and i know that this is a 30-year miss
connection
posting this is a bit of a long shot at
best but i'll try anyway
signed dan 30 year
lost connection folks this guy has been
thinking about that moment for 30
[ __ ] years
man he [ __ ] up
[Music]
yeah best of luck to him though so dan
and torrance is looking for you
so three let me get this straight
the three women from 30 years ago if you
guys remember him from stardust hotel
playing blackjack
here we're still hoping to have get make
that threesome happen
that's awesome there's three women so
for something there's a four hopefully
the three women are still friends
and connected themselves they probably
have families and stuff but [ __ ] it
you know lost connections are lost
connections yeah hey man the 90s were
crazy you gotta make it right
who are we missing sitting on his mind
for so long yeah i've got some
uh all right this one is called uh you
almost hit me with your car
in west hollywood i had just come out of
32 advanced dentistry office
thought i could make it across santa
monica between you and the car in front
of you
i didn't want to run and you didn't want
to slow down
anyway i think we could balance each
other out
couldn't tell if you were local or just
passing through
but on the chance that you live between
la cienega
and crescent heights boulevard maybe we
could slow things down
really make that connection
not funny they really almost had a
collision but there was a
maybe a spark of a romance there i mean
she almost hit him with his car and what
he like locked eyes
yeah and he was like oh yeah
my favorite part of this one though is
that
he had this connection he's interested
in finding this person but
he does have a strict parameter of if
she lives between
la cienega and crescent heights
boulevard
which is basically just like a one block
area
like if she knows he knows where she
lives almost
that's what it makes it sound like he
knows who she is you know where she
lives
is all of this a threat maybe he has a
tether on his foot
can't leave that perimeter oh he's got
uh
maybe he's oh yeah maybe
does his life flash before his eyes and
past and future with her
right all right and then i i got one
other but this one um
we need we need a little bit of a darker
tone for this one yeah
thank you in fact let me um
let me change my background real quick
to something more appropriate
let's see
take me there come on down
come on that looks kind of cheap that's
not actually yeah that's terrible
this lonely uh is that lonely it's kind
of isolated it's off by itself i could
take a dip there
[Music]
this one's called a man recalls
a man recalls the moment when seated
with his lover outside of fisherman's
hut
he drank away the tears which fell on
her white hand
now now that he's wasting away with
longing
he realizes those tears must
have been poisoned ah miss you babe
it was beautiful then so here's a lot of
twists and turns in that one too um
yeah i i guess he's writing a poem for
his ex or something it was a little
unclear
because he's saying her tears are poison
but he misses her
yeah it's a poem yeah this is this isn't
[ __ ] uh
workshop tell me about the lost
connections and move on
it's very profound all right
that's that well i hope james charles
doesn't get any lost connections but
i'll tell you
i have um i'll tell you what i'll have
some lost connections with you guys
until friday be missing you oh
not you you're talking to the audience
yeah the audience
oh i get plenty of you guys
all right well with a whomp womp
and uh yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
uh we'll see you guys on friday when eel
is here
this felt like a low energy episode i'm
just tired
and frankly grossed out by james
i wanted to do a full recap i mean it
was a bummer but i felt like
i felt like it was a worth doing so
hopefully the womb
won't sprout you up
[Music]
nice anyway that's it so we'll be back
on friday guys and uh we'll appreciate
you and see you then all right take care
tata this is ethan off the rails
without ela uh with ethan klein thank
you
end the game
[Music]
[Music]